[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم يوم دامن في شمال سوريا
الدفاع المدني يعلن مقتل احد عشر شخصا
واصابه عشرات في قصف جنه طائرات روسيه على
مدينه جسر الشغور ومحيط ادلب كما تتهم
المعارضه قوات النظام بشن قصف مدفعي على
بلده سرمين شمالي البلاد ما دعى عشرات
العائلات الى الفرار من المنطقه
تستكمل سحب قواتها من المقاطعات الروسيه
وتعود الى قواعدها بعد اعلان وقفه تصعيد
اثر الوساطه البيلاروسيه وسلطات ترفع
الحظر عن حركات السير في مقاطعات عده
وتبقي على اجراءات مكافحه الارهاب في
موسكو
جيش الاحتلال يقول ان مسلحين فلسطينيين
اطلقوا النار على دوريه للجيش الاسرائيلي
عند مدخل مستوطني يسار جنوب مدينه نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه مضيفا ان قواته ردت باطلاق
النيران على المهاجمين الذين لا ذووا
بالفرار بينما دفع جيش الاحتلال بتعزيزات
واغلق مداخل بعض القرى الفلسطينيه في
المنطقه حجاج بيت الله الحرام يؤدون طواف
القدوم استعدادا لبدء مناسك الحج وسلطات
السعوديه تقول ان عدد الحجاج القادمين عبر
المنافذ الدوليه المملكه بلغ اكثر من
مليون و600 الف حاج بينما تتوقع وزاره
الحج ان يصل العدد الاجمالي للحجاج هذا
العام الى نحو مليونين و300 الف حاج
قادمين من نحو 160 دوله
الى اللقاء